hello I'm Adam and welcome back to
police station grenade today we're
taking a look back at watchdogs the
hacker filled storyline which becomes
extremely convoluted so if you play
watchdogs to best watch this thirst
let's do this in watchdogs you play as
Aiden Pearce a morally great individual
who is a hacker by trade after a job
goes wrong a hit is put out on Aiden and
although he survives his niece Lena does
not Aiden locates the Hitman and hands
him over to his bezzie mate Jordan chin
for interrogation suddenly another
sinister chap named Damien asks hidden
to hack their former bosses files Aiden
refuses and Damon kidnaps his sister to
prompt Aiden to change his mind
okay whoa Aiden complies with their
means demands and begins working with
Claire allele a member of dedsec a
criminal activist group and the pair
look at delaford weird yet another
hacker who has information about every
individual in Chicago this information
keeps the police at bay as everyone has
a few skeletons in their closet the data
is of course encrypted so Clara and
Aiden find Raymond Kenny who after a
little coercing decodes the data agent
attacks Wade's compound killing him and
stealing all his data yet another hacker
JB default Markovic steals the day to
aid in his stealing and deletes the
original version of the data does that
make sense
anyway markavitch leaves Aiden proof of
Clara's involvement in his niece's
murder and to make matters worse Damien
informs the world of Aiden's misdeeds
and now everyone is after our hero
eventually Aiden and Raymond aka t-bone
tick down Markovic and take back all the
data
Nicole is then located and freed before
the finale of the story we learn the
identity of the man who put the original
hit on Aiden who is an old man named
Quinn Aiden shuts down his pacemaker and
Quinn dies but only after he reveals
that he ordered the hit because he
thought that Aiden was searching for
blackmail footage of the mayor of the
city of Chicago who accidentally killed
his secretary
Aiden rushes to Clara who is now under
attack but he can't save her and she
leaves him a touching voicemail and
Aiden is now ready to face off with
Damien in a lighthouse of all places
as Aiden confronts Damien his BFF from
earlier Jordan Qin now reveals he is
working for Damien Eden is a bit pissed
off now and kills Damien but only
injures his former best mate Jody
the game ends with Aiden accepting his
new life as an antihero named the
vigilante and vows to keep the city safe
just like a modern-day Batman but wait
there's more after the credits roll
Jordy all guilt-ridden tells Eden where
the original hitman who killed his niece
is and the player must decide whether to
kill him or spare him Aidan's final act
is to upload evidence of Chicago's mayor
killing his secretary and the game ends
did you manage to keep up with that if
so congratulations I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade please subscribe for
more videos like this one see you next
time